en el primer vídeo del valor razonable
para futuros vimos como este es el
precio el cual un inversionista podría
ser neutro entre comprar acciones en un
mercado de valores o comprarlas dentro
de un mes en un contrato futuro pero lo
que me interesa interpretar o resaltar
en este vídeo es saber cómo
interpretarlo para lograr obtener un
precio razonable pero hablando
principalmente de los futuros así que
imagina que despiertas un día por la
mañana y que el mercado de valores aún
no ha abierto entonces observas que la
acción
abc detiene la siguiente cuota o bien
que su valor razonable de acuerdo al
cierre de un día anterior está negociado
en 102 dólares mientras tanto en el
mercado de futuros se comercializa a un
precio de 101 dólares y esto es porque
el mercado de futuros quienes
comercializan más allá del mercado de
valores trabajan las 24 horas por lo que
podrás preguntarte como yo podría
utilizar entonces esta información o
cómo podría aplicarla puesto que en el
mercado de futuros están negociando en
dicho precio
más ellos la puede estar negociando
dicha acción por debajo de su valor
razonable aunque parezca algo en lógico
por cómo se comporta y esto se puede
realizar pues si nos fijamos en el valor
del cierre del día anterior esto nos
dice que las cosas en el mercado quedan
dependiendo al cierre pero los que
negocian los futuros visualizan que
quizás el precio de los 101 dólares sea
neutro entre el valor de la acción y el
precio del futuro entonces no se sabe en
realidad cuál es ese precio puesto que
el futuro se está manejando en 101
dólares lo que significa que la acción
puede estar por debajo quizá un poco y
haciendo bien los cálculos puede que
esto implique que la acción se esté
manejando en estos 99 dólares por lo que
el camino que se debería de seguir en
esto es que quizás suene sencillo
hacerlo pero a la hora de aplicarlo no
lo sea tanto esto es que en algunas
etapas de cuando el mercado de valores
abre la acción tiende a irse para abajo
y puede imaginar tu reacción en este
momento has de decir wow esto es
increíble luce como un indicador a
futuro
y luce demasiado atractivo pues esto
puede que sea muy probable que cuando la
bolsa abra la acción si esté por debajo
pero desafortunadamente o
afortunadamente no se se tienen muchas y
muy sofisticadas frecuencias altas de
los negociadores quienes tienen todo un
equipo configurado que se encarga de
observar y controlar todo ese tipo de
movimientos en la acción y como serán
realmente rápidos en la optimización de
este problema será poco probable que
algún negociador logre tomar ventaja
ante este tipo de fluctuaciones en la
acción ahora si dijéramos que el
contrato de un futuro se está manejando
en 102 dólares esto implicaría que el
precio de la acción estaría en 100
dólares y digamos que al precio del
cierre del mercado en esta situación es
de 105 dólares pues el mercado de
futuros
ahora especula que la acción estará por
arriba de lo que implica y entonces
nosotros no lo vamos a calcular
exactamente pero vamos a especular que
este precio está en 105 dólares
ahora si tú ves esto con el precio del
futuro más allá del valor razonable en
el mercado
va a significar que el precio de la
acción ahora tiende a subir una vez más
si puede que sea hasta 103 dólares en
lugar de 100 como ves todo puede ir
variando dependiendo si la acción
llegara a bajar o llegará a subir
después del cierre pero esto tomar
ventaja se vuelve cada vez más
complicado pues los movimientos son
rápidos